Have you ever wondered what it sounds
like to be direct with someone? How to
be direct in speaking to someone? Well,
this episode is for you. We're going to
get right to the point, short, concise,
direct, all that more. Let's go.
Welcome to the Jefferson Fisher podcast
where I'm on a mission to make your next
conversation [music] the one that
changes everything. If you are listening
on any platform, I'm going to ask that
you find the button that that says
subscribe [music]
or like or comment because it helps this
podcast and it tells wherever you're
listening that this is good quality
[music] content and that's my promise
that if you listen to these episodes and
subscribe to them, I'm going to make you
a better communicator. Thank you. This
podcast is sponsored by, you know it,
Cozy Earth. I love Cozy Earth because
all of their products are extremely
premium, comfortable, and cozy. From bed
sheets to bath towels to
um
house shoes. To be honest, I've their
house shoes if for those who've been
listening to these episodes, they're
still killing it. I have been wearing
these things around the house and
they're fantastic. So, I um I can't
recommend Cozy Earth enough. We have
their bed sheets, we have their bath
they have these bath sheets these like
bath towels that are as tall as me. I'm
over 6 ft and they're huge and they're
awesome. So, if you like quality
products, you like things that are
comfortable and cozy, look no further
than Cozy Earth. go to
cozyearth.com/jefferson,
use the code Jefferson and get up to 20%
off. That's cozyearth.com/jefferson,
off. Let's keep going.
I speak to a lot of people, not just I
don't mean that in
I people in the world, I mean
specifically in my job as an attorney. I
speak to a lot of people and I train a
lot of people in how to communicate. And
one of the number one things that I hear
time and time again is Jefferson, I wish
I could just I'm I'm I'm I'm not very
direct when it comes to depositions,
cross-examination, direct examination,
when I answer questions from people. I
have a really hard time being direct and
I and I wish that I I wasn't that way.
If that's you, if you're listening and
go, "I wish I could be more direct. I
really don't know how it sounds and I
really don't know how to do it."
This is the episode. I'm going to teach
you exactly how to do it. So, what is
being direct? It is a straight line from
A to B.
That's what it is.
No farther than what it needs to be, no
longer than what it needs to be. It is
not a detour. I want you to think of it
like Goo- Google Maps or Waze or
whatever you, you know, however you um
maybe MapQuest, anybody? Any- um Think
of it as a straight line. You you're not
taking any detours, you're not taking
the scenic route in the conversation.
You are getting there as fast as you
can, most efficiently as you can.
Yes, it's not artful. Yes, it's not
uh some fancy-sounding,
very flowery language. It's just getting
right to the point of exactly what you
need to say. So, that's that's what
direct is.
What does direct sound like? It direct
sounds like your words sticking,
not stretching, not expanding. So, think
of it like in the Olympics, right? They
have um in gymnastics in the Summer
Olympics and these gymnasts who are
amazing
do these amazing things in the air and
then what's the goal here? They want to
stick the landing. They do or they talk
they say they do what they need to do.
The action is up here and then they
stick the landing right there and then
they throw their hands in the air and
everybody applauds.
That's what you're looking for. You're
not looking for the type of motion where
it continues just to carry on and on and
on where it's not like, I don't know,
just watch the Winter Olympics. I'm
thinking of like curling, you know,
where they they do the ice the the block
of ice and I don't really know how it
works but it seems kind of cool. Then
they have like their mops. Anyway, so
how can we do this in your everyday
communication? Here is a key and
something that
is might be a hidden gem. In my opinion,
speaking to customer service agents on
the phone is the number one training
ground for learning to speak directly.
We all know what it's like to be on the
phone with a customer service agent and
it's 20 minutes later, 30 minutes later
and you go, "This is
This is unbearable. This is terrible. I
I'm confused. They don't really know
what I'm saying. I don't know how to get
what I want." And it's just defeating.
Most of the time it has to do not with
the agent, has to do with how direct you
are being, what you are asking for. So,
I'm going to give you
a 1 2 3
that's going to help you not only be
more direct but also probably help with
some customer service agents. Now, first
I want to call it what it is. Customer
service reps, they don't have all this
space usually to be creative. They have
very limited options in what they can do
like a doctor or an attorney or
different occupations where it's like a
triage. If it's not this, then it's that
and it's this decision tree of
information and that's what they're
trained on. So, if you don't fall into
one of those categories, they don't
really know how to help. And what makes
it worse are these problems. One, you
begin with the story.
You begin with a story. So, you start
saying, "Okay, so the other day I bought
this thing and I and it is not really
working and I'm not really sure." And
you start giving all the background
context. That is not helpful and it's
not sounding direct at all. It makes it
harder and prolongs the issue. Another
mistake is where you kind of hint at
what you want them to do and just expect
them to kind of read your mind rather
than being direct and asking for what
you want. And three, you overexplain and
overtalk to where you feel as if they're
going to feel you're justified and so
entitled and it's going to lead them
directly to the answer.
You see how how you're dealing with
customer service in that way can be the
same exact thing of how you deal with
ordinary people. You you you might have
the tendency to expect them to read your
mind.
You might have the tendency to feel like
they should already know what you want
and where you're going and so you don't
feel that inner desire to be direct. You
just expect that they naturally know
where you're going and that you're
entitled to something and it's their job
to get it. But in truth, it's your job
to be direct. That's why I say that the
customer service
on the phone with them is a great
training ground because you can learn to
say things more concisely and you don't
I'm not at all saying, let me make this
very clear.
Do not call customer service just for
the fun of it and be rude and be ugly
and say things and that is not cool and
that is not at all what I'm saying.
What I am saying is that for you to be
direct, you have to practice it and
these little customer service
interactions, whether it's a wait staff
or it's a hotel staff or it's customer
service, these are chances for you to
practice and say exactly what you want.
Before we get going, I want to tell you
about ButcherBox. When life gets busy
and you don't know what you're going to
eat for dinner cuz we've all been there.
You're just standing and staring at the
fridge or at the pantry and you don't
know what you're going to make for
dinner and the kids are going crazy and
you go, "I don't know what's going to
happen." ButcherBox, thank goodness for
ButcherBox and my family. It makes
dinner planning simple. ButcherBox
delivers over 100 premium protein
options straight to your door including
100% grass-fed beef, free-range organic
chicken, crate-free pork, and
wild-caught seafood. For over a decade,
they've led the industry with meat and
seafood that's antibiotic-free,
hormone-free, and independently verified
clean, trustworthy protein you can feel
good about. We had one last night. I won
the ribeyes. It was great. Every product
meets the same high standards whether
you're cooking steaks or throwing
chicken in the air fryer on a busy
night. And with fully customizable
plans, it fits your routine and your
schedule. In our house, we generally
like just the ground beef, the steaks,
and the chicken. That's Chicken is my my
kids love the chicken. ButcherBox has
these chicken like tenders and they hit
every single time with my kids. So,
simple staples that make it easy to stay
on track. As an exclusive offer, new
listeners can get their choice between
organic ground beef, chicken breast, or
shrimp in every box for a year. Plus,
$20 off when you go to
butcherbox.com/jefferson.
Your choice of organic ground beef,
chicken breast, or shrimp in every box
for an entire year. That sounds awesome.
Plus, $20 off your first box and free
shipping as always. That's
butcherbox.com/jefferson.
Don't forget to use our link so they
know that we sent you. All right, let's
keep going.
How do How do I speak more direct? I'm
so glad you asked. So, here's how to do
it. Number one, state the issue in one
sentence.
In one sentence. For example,
there's been a charge on my account.
This product was not delivered.
This is the problem.
So, if you have a uh an uh uh
So, if you have a problem, if you have a
hard time
describing what the issue is, just
finish the sentence, "This is my
problem, blank."
"Blank is my problem."
Be very, very clear on exactly what the
issue is. Number two, you have to state
the impact.
What has been the impact to you?
There's a charge on my account.
It cost me $75. Dollars.
Uh this is late. I am not able to do
this. State the impact, the harm, the
consequence. It's very similar to kind
of like in legal things, you have to
write a petition. State a petition. And
in a petition, which is a written
document, you state the issue, you state
the harm,
and who's responsible for it. It's same
kind of principle. You're having to
state why they are responsible. So
first, you have the issue. Second, you
have the impact. And third, you state
the remedy. What you're wanting them to
do.
I've had a charge on my account. It's
$75.
I want this money back.
I need a refund. I want to exchange
this. I need to X.
Be
explicit as possible, specific as
possible. This is where you get to say,
that doesn't work for me.
Nope.
I don't agree with that.
Like for some people, that is really
hard to do.
They have a hard time pushing against
that. It's an uncomfortable feeling. You
get to train that. It's It is a learned
skill. Believe me, it is a learned
skill. You can do this.
I have three separate boxes here. You're
going to state what the problem is,
two, state the impact, and three, state
the resolution.
What are you asking for? What are you
needing them to do? You can apply this
at home,
at work, anytime. When you get to say,
here is my problem,
here's the impact to me, here's what I'm
asking you to do. Here's how you can fix
it. Here's the fix that I've come up
with. Don't do it to where you just
state the problem and go, I leave it up
to you.
Find the solution.
Ask exactly for the solution that you
want. Now, if you say, I want a refund,
and customer service says, I'm sorry,
sir, we can't do this. You say, that's
not acceptable, then what are my other
options?
Ask, what are my other options?
Is there a way that I can escalate this?
What What is a solution that that is
available to me?
How can I escalate this?
Like they all have a procedure in their
book of what to do when. And yeah, maybe
you you do hit a
a a dead end.
But you can at least
rest assured that you've been direct
about it and stating what you want. And
no, you're not You're not going to use
that company again. You You You know,
you're going to cut off the relationship
with that because it's They're not
giving you what you want. Same thing
with everyday human relationships.
And in romantic relationships or dating
relationships. If you are not being
direct and stating what you want, you
are setting yourself up for failure. It
This kind of reminds me of this quote
that I heard, and it's something to the
tune of, the single biggest problem
with communication
is the illusion that it has taken place.
Right? Like where you think you were
very direct, and the other person
doesn't feel that at all. They They're
left confused. The sharper you can be
and say, hey,
this is what you said. This hurt me. I
want you to apologize.
It's kind of the same It's all the same
system.
It's all the same system.
Hey, you left your
your toys out.
Your LEGOs out. I stepped on one of
them, and it caused me immense pain. I
need you to pick these up now. True
story for me, many nights. Right? You
see how it is bam, bam, bam. You're
sticking the landing every single time.
It could be also as simple as
I know that you've want this from me.
That's something I'm not comfortable
with. My answer needs to be no.
Period. Stick the landing every time. I
really like that phrase, my answer needs
to be no.
I need to say no.
Mhm.
What a great phrase.
Whenever you can be very direct with
somebody, they actually appreciate it
more. I like to to to say that sometimes
the kindest thing you can do is be as
direct as you can be.
When you're not direct with somebody,
you're indirect, it's
like it's trying to go through the back
door. Like there's a front door on a
house for a reason. Go up and knock on
it. Go through the front door. You're
not going to try and find a window
that's open somewhere else. Go through
the front door. That's what it's there
for.
People who struggle with being direct,
it's usually because you're not using
the right type of frame or system to
deliver the message. You typically start
instead with a story, and you're giving
context.
Before we keep going, I want to take a
moment to tell you about Momentous.
Momentous is a company that I've been
using long before they were ever a
sponsor of this podcast. To me, they
make the top-tier supplements in a space
that
typically has a lot of low regulation.
Like people cut corners, they just throw
in a lot of sugar and things. They don't
really tell you what's all in the
product. That's why I partnered with
Momentous. They're known as a high-trust
brand in a low-trust category by holding
themselves to a higher bar, which they
don't have to do, but they do it. They
call it the Momentous standard. It's all
about quality, testing, and transparency
done the right way. Momentous uses
top-tier ingredients, like grass-fed
whey protein from European dairy cows
and the purest form of creatine
monohydrate with no fillers or
artificial sweeteners. And every product
is independently certified by NSF for
sport or Informed Sport, so you know
it's tested for contaminants and
verified for label accuracy, which makes
me feel a whole lot better. In a space
where trust is rare, Momentous is
changing the game. Right now, you can
get 35% off your first order with promo
code Jefferson at livemomentous.com.
That's livemomentous.com,
promo code Jefferson. And now, let's
keep going. This happens a lot in the
law firm.
We'll have a new client, potential
client, who calls, and they talk to the
receptionist, and they go, okay, so the
other day, like uh 3 months ago, I had
this guy, and he did this, and you know,
I did And they start saying
all of the tea All this context that's
been
in their mind, and it's all story, and
it's convoluted, and they're like, no,
wait, wait. And so this guy And they
start dropping names, and then they're
like, well, he did this, and then
actually, you know what? Wait, let me
back up. What he did was That is
maddening.
All right?
I understand that it usually comes from
insecurity or fear, and it's it's the
fear of that you're not giving enough
information. Totally valid. What the
other person hears and what the other
person is doing is trying to distill
like Okay, what's what's relevant?
What's not relevant? What's the issue?
What's not the issue? And it's it It's
like playing
um
um like an I spy book game. Like a
Where's Waldo? Like you just You're
searching for the things that go, that's
the issue right there.
But not everybody does that. They're not
going to just try to find the issues for
you in that type of capacity. Instead,
they're going to be just as lost. So,
what are they going to do? They're going
to say what they want because they don't
really know what you're asking for. So
you start with a story, I can promise
you you're going to end up being
disappointed when it comes to being
direct. Unless Let's say unless there
was a reason why the story
is important,
and that would come on the back end.
So instead, I would say, here's my
issue. Here's the impact to me. Here's
how I want you
to fix it.
And they're going to give a response,
and you say, I'm going to give you more
information because you need to know
this.
Right?
That's when you're able to give the
additional information, but you don't
want to start with it
because it sounds like
you're trying to
I don't know, r- run up
go up on a escalator that's going down.
Like you're just going to be running in
motion and not getting anywhere. All
right, we've talked about what being
direct is. We've talked about what being
direct sounds like, how you want to
stick the landing, how you want to have
short, choppy sentences. In my world,
what I like to teach is if you can't say
it in three sentences,
you need to think about it again. You
need to condense, you need to reduce.
So, if Let me give that little tidbit to
you. I have a three-sentence rule that I
like to live by both in my company and
regular communication, if need be. If
And it's this, if I can't say it in
three sentences,
I need to go back and think about it.
Now, the other people, if they're asking
for information on something, and they
need context, absolutely. I'm I'm going
to give that.
But in terms of me initiating a message,
if I cannot say it
in three sentences, not run-on
sentences, but actual grammatical
sentences, then I need to go back to the
drawing board. It's that that quote
about if I would I would have written
you a shorter letter if I had had more
time. Like it takes effort to try and
condense information down. And so when I
can do that, that's me being direct. And
when I can use the method that we just
talked about, what I just taught you of
stating first what the issue is, to say,
this is my problem.
Two, this is the impact to me, how it
has affected me. And three, the fix, the
resolution, the result. This is what I
am asking you to do.
Whether it's just to listen, whether
it's just to note it for the record,
whether it is to
um compensate me to be able to recover
something back in some way to remedy
this.
That is a system that you can use in a
lot of different contexts. And here, the
main focus is stick your landing.
And that's exactly what I'm going to do
right now. All right, thank you. Bye.
Try that and follow me.